>>> IT'S WEEK THREE.
IT'S NFL.
YOU JUST TAPPED INTO "THE SQUAD
RIDE."
LIVE IN THE BLEACHER REPORT APP.
MY NAME IS CONNOR ROGERS
ALONGSIDE THE MAN OF THE PEOPLE.
HE'S ALWAYS GOT THE GOOD STUFF
TO GIVE AWAY.
GREG, HOW ARE WE FEELING?
I KNOW YOU HAVE SOMETHING IN
YOUR POCKET TO HAND OUT ALREADY.
>> CONNOR, FEELING GREAT.
AND YOU KNOW WHAT I GOT IN MY
POCKET.
I GOT HOODIES.
I GOT JERSEYS.
BUT I ALSO HAVE THE HANDY DANDY
iPAD RIGHT HERE.
FOR THE PEOPLE THAT DON'T KNOW,
THIS IS HOW YOU GET THE JERSEYS.
THIS IS HOW YOU GET THE HOODIES.
IT ALL HAPPENS RIGHT HOAR ON THE
HANDY DANDY iPAD.
CONNOR, I AM IN THE COMMENTS
RIGHT NOW.
I'MAPIZZASHIP, HE HAS THE NICK
CHUBB GIFT.
SHOUT-OUT TO THE USER NAME AND
SHOUT-OUT TO THE GIFT.
ROCKING OUT WITH NICK CLUB.
IT JUST WENT AWAY.
THERE IT IS, THOUGH, CONNOR.
YOU'RE WALKING AWAY WITH THE
FIRST PIZZA TODAY.
>> THIS IS THE SHOW WHERE WE BET
ANY TIME TOUCHDOWN SCORES.
LAST WEEK WE ROAD WITH OSCAR19
AND CHRISTIAN McCAFFREY.
IT WORKED OUT WELL.
IT HIT.
McCAFFREY GOT INTO THE END ZONE
ON THE GROUND.
HE GOT IN THE END ZONE THROUGH
THE AIR LAST WEEKEND.
SO ON FRIDAY WE ASKED YOU ON
SOCIAL AND IN THE APP, DROP YOUR
LOCKS TO SCORE A TOUCHDOWN.
AND THESE ARE THE MOST POPULAR
PICKS YOU SENT US.
AT THE TOP DEREK HENRY COMING
OFF A MONSTER WEEKEND.
TRAVIS KELCE ALREADY FOUND THE
END ZONE THREE TIMES THIS YEAR.
SAQUON BARKLEY HAS NOT SCORED
THIS YEAR.
>> SURPRISING.
BUT HE HAS THE FALCONS.
A COUPLE TOP FLIGHT WIDE
RECEIVER AND A GUY IN TJ
HOCKENSON WITH A STRUGGLING
LIONS TEAM.
WE HAVE A TON OF GREAT VIDEOS
FROM YOU LAST WEEK.
CAN'T FEATURE THEM ALL, BUT WE
HAVE TO SHOW YOU A COUPLE OF
GOOD ONES.
>> LAST WEEK.
I'M TAKING IT THIS WEEK.
IT IS A LOCK EVERY WEEK.
>> YOUR LOCK.
>> OH, MY GOSH.
>> HERE WE GO.
>> IF I LAND ON BOTH, WE'RE
FLIPPING A COIN.
OH.
>> NO THANK YOU.
>> OH, MY GOSH.
OH!
>> WHAT'S THAT?
>> STEFON DIGGS.
>> NAJEE HARRIS.
>> DEREK HENRY.
>> LOCK IT IN EVERY WEEK.
>> MAKE MONEY.
LET'S MAKE SOME MONEY, BOYS.
>> LET'S MAKE SOME MONEY.
GREG, I KNOW YOU GOT THE
HOODIES, BUT WHAT ELSE ARE YOU
GIVING AWAY TODAY?
>> CONNOR, I'M NOT ONLY GIVING
AWAY HOODIES TODAY BUT I'M
GIVING OUT TWO NFL GIFT CARDS.
ONE GOES TO THE WINNER OF THE
LOCK LEGEND CONTEST THAT WE'RE
GOING TO DO.
AND ONE OF THOSE TWO ARE LUCKY,
LUCKY COMMENTARY.
TO GET IN THE COMMENTS AND DO
WHAT YOU DO.
IF YOU NEED A JERSEY, IF YOU
NEED A JERSEY, I NEED GIFTS, I
NEED EMOJIS.
BUT, CONNOR, I NEED WINNERS
ONLY.
PLEASE, CONNOR.
PLEASE SAY THE PLEASE, TOO.
>> PLEASE.
ALL RIGHT.
WE HAVE FOUR LEGENDARY PICKS TO
SHOW YOU.
YOU KNOW THE DEAL BY NOW.
THE LAST ONE STANDING IS THE
SQUAD RIDE LEADER.
THEY GET THE JERSEY.
THEY GET THE STREET CREDIT
BECAUSE THEY ARE PICKING WHO'S
GETTING IN THE END ZONE AND THAT
THING IS GETTING BOOSTED IN
DRAFT KINGS.
IT'S TIME FOR ROUND ONE, OUR
FIRST PITCH COMES FROM RYAN.54.
RYAN, TELL US WHO IS SCORING A
TOUCHDOWN TODAY?
>> I GOT MONDAY NIGHT FOOTBALL.
BILLS VERSUS COWBOYS.
>> WE'RE GOING TO ASK THEM.
WE'RE GOING TO ASK THEM.
>> AMARI COOPER AND RIGHT HAND
FOR DEVONTA SMITH.
WHO IS SCORING A TOUCHDOWN?
RIGHT HAND, DEVONTA SMITH IT IS.
LET'S GO.
>> I THINK RYAN OUT THERE JUST
WALKING AROUND DISNEY WORLD
ASKING FOR LOCKS.
BOLD STRATEGY.
BUT A NICE PICK IN DEVONTA
SMITH.
AS ALWAYS, WE DEFINE A
CHALLENGER FOR RYAN.
SO WE'RE GOING OUT AND LOOKING
FOR ONE FROM DEN HARDING.
MATT WITH OUR SECOND PITCH OF
THE DAY.
LET'S SEE WHAT IT IS, MATT.
>> ALL RIGHT.
WE GOT THREE TENNIS BALLS.
WE GOT TJ HOCKENSON, TRAVIS
KELCE RIGHT HERE AND GEORGE
KITTLE.
WHICHEVER BALL GETS STUCK IN THE
FENCE IS SCORING A TOUCHDOWN
THIS WEEKEND, ALL RIGHT?
ALL RIGHT.
HERE WE GO.
TJ HOCKENSON TOUCHDOWN, IT'S A
LOCK.
>> ALL RIGHT.
YOU HEARD THE FIRST TWO PITCHES.
GREG, ARE YOU RIDING WITH THE
DISNEY BEAR LEGEND OR MATT, THE
TENNIS LEGEND, SHOWING OFF SOME
ATHLETICISM TO "THE SQUAD RIDE".
>> ACTUALLY I HAVE A QUESTION.
I'LL BET YOU $100 IF YOU CAN
TELL ME WHO THAT DISNEY
CHARACTER IS IN THAT FIRST
VIDEO.
>> OH, MAN.
ODDS PLUS A MILLION.
I HAVE NO IDEA.
>> I HAVE LITERALLY NO IDEA WHO
THAT IS, BUT I DO KNOW ABOUT THE
PICK.
DEVONTA SMITH TAKING ON THE
COWBOYS TODAY.
I LIKE THE PICK PLUS 150.
YOU KNOW WHAT WE CAN DO HERE AS
WELL.
TJ HOCKENSON, SHOUT-OUT TO THE
TENNIS LEGEND, LOVE THE VIDEO.
YOU KNOW, THAT TOOK PRACTICE OR
SOMETHING.
>> OR A COUPLE OF THINGS.
>> IT SPOKE TO ME.
A COUPLE OF TAKES.
MAYBE ONE, MAYBE TWO, MAYBE
THREE.
I DON'T KNOW.
BUT SHOUTS OUT TO THE VIDEO, BUT
I'M LEANING TOWARDS DEVONTA
SMITH.
I DON'T KNOW, CONNOR.
WHAT ABOUT YOU?
>> MAN, I LIKE THE TENNIS VIDEO
BETTER.
BUT I'M LEANING TOWARD THE
DEVONTA SMITH MORE.
I THINK THAT WILL BE A
SHOOT-OUT.
WE'RE GOING TO TALK ABOUT THAT
LATER.
I FEEL GOOD ABOUT DEVONTA SMITH
ESPECIALLY PLUS MONEY.
PLUS MONEY THERE.
BUT IT DOESN'T MATTER WHAT YOU
OR I THINK.
IT IS UP TO THE PEOPLE.
HOW ARE THEY DECIDING THIS ONE?
>> CONNOR, I AM IN THE COMMENTS
RIGHT HERE.
I'M IN THE HANDY DANDY, SEEING A
LOT OF GIFs.
SHOUT-OUT TO RED WHITE AND SAINT
LOU.
THEY GOT TYLER MURRAY, EVEN
THOUGH THAT HAS NOTHING TO DO
WITH WHAT WE'RE TALKING ABOUT.
BUT, BROTHER, YOU ARE HERE SO
SHOUT-OUT TO YOU.
I GOT DEEP GEEK SAYING HOCKENSON
DEFINITELY.
SHOUT-OUT TO YOU.
WINNERS ONLY, PLEASE.
AND HE HAS A GIF OF TJ
HOCKENSON.
SO CONNOR --
>> PEOPLE ARE GOING AGAINST US.
>> THEY'RE GOING AGAINST US, BUT
I'M VIBING WITH IT.
WHY NOT?
IT APPEARS THE PEOPLE HAVE
SPOKEN.
THE TENNIS LEGEND MOVING ON TO
THE NEXT ROUND.
>> I'M OKAY WITH THAT.
THE FIRST ROUND GOES TO DEN
HARDING, MATT, THE TENNIS LEGEND
WITH TJ HOCKENSON, BUT YOU STILL
HAVE TWO CHALLENGERS REMAINING.
SO ON TO ROUND TWO.
OUR NEXT PITCH COMES FROM A
FAMILIAR ONE.
WHO DO YOU GOT?
BUTTERCUP IS GOING TO GIVE US
THE LOCK.
WHO IS IT, BUTTERCUP?
DK METCALF?
I DON'T THINK SO.
WHERE IS SHE GOING?
TRAVIS KELCE, LOCK IT IN.
TRAVIS KELCE FROM BUTTERCUP.
ALL RIGHT.
YOU HEARD FROM THE BUTTERCUP
LEGEND.
CRAIG, WHO ARE YOU RIDING WITH?
THIS IS TOUGH.
YOU HAVE THE TENNIS LEGEND.
YOU HAVE THE BUTTERCUP SWIM
LEGEND.
WE LIKE KELSEY THIS WEEK.
WHO ARE YOU RIDING WITH?
>> WELL, BEFORE I GET MY TAKE,
WHAT I NEED EVERYBODY TO DO IS
GET IN THE COMMENTS AND LET US
KNOW IF YOU ARE RIDING WITH
TRAVIS KELCE OR HOCKENSON AND
THE TENNIS LEGEND.
WHAT A CUTE NAME, BUTTERCUP.
WHAT A CUTE NAME.
BUT THE SWIMMING EXECUTION,
CONNOR, THERE WAS NO SPEED --
>> NO URGENCY.
>> SO NO URGENCIES, JUST
STRAIGHT VIBING.
ACTUALLY, I LIKE THAT.
YOU KNOW WHAT, I'M WINNING
MYSELF OVER RIGHT NOW.
I LIKE THE VIBES IN THE VIDEO.
I LIKE THE DOGGY PADDLE AND I
LIKE THE PICK, TRAVIS KELCE.
YOU KNOW WHAT WE CAN DO HERE
WITH THE MINUS 140.
I MIGHT BE LEANING THIS WAY,
CONNOR.
WHICH WAY ARE YOU LEANING?
>> I'M GOING WITH THE BUTTERCUP
LEGEND, THE SWIM, THE DOG
LEGEND.
EVERY SINGLE WEEK THERE IS A DOG
VIDEO.
I'M NOT PICKING AGAINST IT.
LET'S GIVE THAT TO SOME PLUS
MONEY.
WHAT DO THE PEOPLE THINK OF THIS
ONE?
>> I AM BACK INTO THE COMMENTS.
I'M BACK ON THE HANDY DANDY.
THE COMMENTS ARE FLYING RIGHT
NOW.
I GOT -- I GOT JACK BOYD 37 SAYS
BUTTERCUP KNOWS THE LOCKS.
SHUT-OUT TO YOU.
YOU ARE WALKING AWAY WITH A
HOODIE.
I ALSO HAVE JOSEPH M.
HE HAS A TRAVIS KELCE GIFT.
THERE IT IS.
>> VERY NICE, YEAH.
>> TRAVIS KELCE GIF.
SO SHOUT-OUT TO YOU.
I'M GOING TO GIVE AWAY ONE MORE.
HERE WE GO.
THIS IS FUNNY.
22 CODY SAYS YOU ARE THE WINNERS
ONLY, PLEASE.
BUT IT HAS A FUNNY, FUNNY GIF
THAT SAYS BUCKLE UP, BUTTERCUP.
SO, CONNOR, I THINK WE CAN MAKE
A DECISION HERE.
>> I THINK BUTTERCUP STOLE
EVERYBODY'S HEART LIKE IN THE
COMMENTS.
I MEAN, THEY STOLE YOUR HEART.
IT WON ME OVER.
HOW COULD IT NOT?
>> JUST DOGGY PADDLING ALONG,
GETTING THE PICK.
THAT'S IT.
SECOND ROUND BELONGS TO
TRAMMELL, BUT HE'S GOT TO DEFEAT
OUR FINAL CONTENDERS TO TAKE
HOME THE JERSEY, TAKE HOME THE
SQUAD RIDE LEADER.
WINNER TAKES IT ALL FINAL ROUND.
LET'S DO IT.
NEXT UP IS SHAWN STONE 514.
LET'S SEE THE PICKS, SHAWN.
YOU GOT A TOUGH ONE.
TOUGH COMPETITION HERE AGAINST
BUTTERCUP.
ALL RIGHT.
YOU HEARD FROM THE RACE CAR
LEGEND.
GOING WITH DEREK HENRY.
IT DID NOT WORK FOR US WEEK ONE.
BUT IF YOU HAD HIM IN FANTASY
WEEK TWO, YOU PROBABLY ONE.
THE MAN ALMOST PUT UP 50 POINTS
IN PPR.
SO THIS IS TOUGH, MAN.
I LIKE TRAVIS -- I'M EXCITED
ABOUT THE TRAVIS KELCE PICK.
I LOVE THE RACE CAR, EXECUTION
OF THAT THERE.
CRAIG, WHO ARE YOU ROLLING WITH?
I DON'T KNOW WHERE TO GO WITH
THIS ONE.
>> CONNOR, THIS ONE IS TOUGH.
LET ME TALK TO THE PEOPLE
BECAUSE, YOU KNOW, I TAP IN TO
THE PEOPLE.
I WANT THEM TO TELL US.
I WANT THEM TO TELL ME.
WHICH WAY SHOULD WE RIDE?
TRAVIS KELCE AND THE BUTTERCUP
LEGEND OR SHOULD WE GO DEREK
HENRY AND THE CAR LEGEND?
YOU GUYS PLEASE LET ME KNOW
BECAUSE I AM CONTEMPLATING.
CONNOR IS ALSO CONTEMPLATING, I
BELIEVE.
I DON'T KNOW.
BUT I'LL TALK ABOUT THE VIDEO,
CONNOR.
I WILL TALK ABOUT THE VIDEO
LEGENDARY.
I MEAN, TOURNAMENT STYLE, BRO.
HE GOT HIS WINNER BY TOURNAMENT
STYLE.
JUST HIM THROWING THE TOURNAMENT
STYLE INTO THE VIDEO IS
LEGENDARY IN ITSELF.
I DON'T KNOW IF YOU HAVE EVER
BEEN WITH YOUR FRIENDS AND YOU
GUYS WENT TO PLAY VIDEO GAMES
AND THERE WAS A BUNCH OF YOU.
YOU WOULD PROBABLY SUGGEST THE
TOURNAMENT STYLE PLAY.
YOU GOT TO MAKE A BRACKET.
SO SHOUT-OUT TO MY GUY FOR THAT.
BUT, CONNOR, DO YOU HAVE A TAKE
ON ANY?
LIKE DO YOU HAVE A TAKE ON
ANYTHING?
WHICH WAY ARE YOU LEANING?
>> YEAH.
LISTEN, NOT EASY.
I'M GOING WITH BUTTERCUP, MAN.
I LOVE THE TRAVIS KELCE THING.
I THINK IT WILL BE A SHOOT-OUT
AGAINST THE CHARGERS.
I COULD SEE THEM EACH THROWING
THREE-QUARTER BACKS IN THIS
GAME.
HE HAS SCORED BOTH WEEKS ALREADY
THIS SEASON.
THIS IS NOT NEW WITH HIM.
HE'S DONE IT FOR YEARS NOW, THE
BEST QUARTERBACK IN THE LEAGUE.
MAN, I'M GOING WITH KELSEY.
I'M GOING WITH BUTTERCUP.
I'M GOING WITH THE BIG SWIM.
BUT WE'RE NOT DECIDING THE SQUAD
RIDE LEADER, MAN.
LET THE COMMENTS TELL US WHO
WE'RE BOOSTING.
>> I WAS JUST -- I'M SORRY.
I'M JUST SO AMPED LIKE RIGHT NOW
BECAUSE YOU JUST MENTIONED THE
QUARTERBACK THAT THROWS TO
TRAVIS KELCE, AND THAT
QUARTERBACK IS ON MY FANTASY
TEAM.
>> A BIG WEEK.
>> I'M ALSO LEANING WITH YOU
TOWARDS BUTTERCUP, BUT IT IS NOT
UP TO ME.
IT IS NOT UP TO YOU, CONNOR.
LET ME GET INTO THESE COMMENTS.
LET ME GET INTO THESE COMMENTS
BECAUSE THIS IS HOW WE'RE GOING
TO DECIDE THE WINNER HERE.
BUTTERCUP IS GETTING A LOT OF
LOVE.
I SEE ASHLEY G. SAYS CAN WE PICK
BOTH?
SHOUT-OUT TO YOU, ASHLEY, FOR
THE VIBES.
I WISH WE COULD PICK BOTH.
THOSE ARE GOOD VIBES.
MOVING ON, MOVING ON, HE SAID,
CAN'T GUARD CUT SAYS I HAD HIM
IN FANTASY WEEK TWO, SO I'M
ROCKING WITH MY BOY KING HENRY.
IT'S A LOCK.
HE HAD HIM IN THAT BIG WEEK.
SHOUT-OUT TO YOU.
YOU ARE WALKING AWAY WITH A
HOODIE.
ONE MORE, CONNOR.
I'LL BE GENEROUS HERE.
ONE MORE.
I GOT JACK BOYD IN THE COMMENTS.
SHOUT-OUT TO JACK BOYD.
HERE WE GO.
NEXT ONE I SEE BECAUSE THE
COMMENTS ARE LITERALLY FLOWING
RIGHT NOW.
NEXT ONE I SEE I'M JUST GOING
TO -- OKAY, HERE WE GO.
GOT A RIDE WITH BUTTERCUP.
THEREFORE, YOU KNOW WHAT THAT
MEANS, CONNOR.
BUTTERCUP, TRAVIS KELSEY, YOU
ARE THE WINNER OF THIS WEEK'S
SQUAD RIDE.
SHOUT-OUT TO YOU GUYS.
LET'S GET A TOUCHDOWN.
WE ARE RIDING, CONNOR.
>> ALSO, ALSO, PULL UP THIS
GRAPHIC.
LET ME SHOW YOU GUYS.
LET ME SHOW YOU GUYS SOMETHING.
>> LET'S GET IT DOWN.
THE GRAPHIC IS RIGHT THERE.
YOU SEE TRAVIS KELCE MINUS 140.
POOF.
THERE IT IS.
YOU GUYS SEE IT.
THAT'S WHAT WE DO HERE ON "SQUAD
RIDE."
THANKS TO OUR FRIENDS AT DRAFT
KINGS.
WE'RE GOING TO BOOST THAT.
THE BETTING SOCIALS FOR A LINK.
SEND US YOUR SCREEN SHOTS OF
YOUR BETS.
LET'S GET RICH THIS SUNDAY,
CONNOR.
LET'S GET RICH.
YOU GOT TO PUT THE VIBES OUT
INTO THE ATMOSPHERE.
SEND US YOUR VIDEOS AND YOUR
CELEBRATIONS.
WE WANT WINNERS AND WINNERS
ONLY, PLEASE.
>> LET'S DO IT.
SHOUT-OUT BUTTERCUP, THE NEW
LOCK LEGEND.
ALL RIGHT.
WE'RE NOT DONE YET.
WE GOT MORE LOCKS TO TALK.
YOU STILL HAVE A JERSEY TO GIVE
AWAY.
BUTTERCUP BETTER GET THAT JERRY,
BY THE WAY, WHOEVER BUTTERCUP'S
OWNER IS.
ALL RIGHT.
COMMUNITY CONTEST, YOU ALL SAW
IT LAST WEEK.
IT WAS THE TALK OF THE BETTING
WORLD.
IT HIT THE FIRST 15 GOING INTO
MONDAY NIGHT FOOTBALL.
NEEDED THAT LINE.
LOOKED FUN IN THE FIRST QUARTER.
EVERYBODY WENT DOWNHILL FROM
THERE.
BUT IF IT DID ANYTHING, GREG, IT
INSPIRED YOU AND I TO MAKE OUR
OWN 16 LEG PARLAY FOR THIS WEEK.
>> YES, SIR.
>> AND EARLY THIS WEEK WE ASKED
FOR YOUR TAKES ON IT.
LET'S TAKE A LOOK AT WHAT PEOPLE
HAD TO SAY ABOUT IT.
THERE IT IS.
WE ALREADY GOT CAROLINA, SO
WE'RE NOT OUT YET.
WE GOT ONE IN THE BOOKS.
A LOT OF BALL GAME LEFT ACROSS
THE BOARD HERE.
WE DO HAVE TWO UPSETS, NOTHING
CRAZY.
BUT THE RAMS BEATING THE BUCKS
AND THE FALCONS TAKING DOWN THE
GIANTS AND A BOARD WITH A LOT OF
FAVORITES.
I WANT TO KNOW WHAT THE PEOPLE
ARE SAYING ABOUT IT, GREG.
>> YEAH.
I NEED YOU GUYS TO GET IN THE
COMMENTS AND TELL ME WHAT YOU
GUYS THINK OF OUR PARLAY.
I'M GIVING OUT HOODIES.
WE ALSO ASKED YOU IN THE APP
EARLIER THIS WEEK LET'S TAKE A
LOOK AT THE FIRST APP COMMENT
FROM DAVID ZIM 93.
LET'S TAKE A LOOK AT THE
COMMENT, CONNOR.
LOVING OUR PARLAY RIGHT HERE.
>> YEAH, EXCITED.
IF YOU GUYS AREN'T WOKKING WITH
US, GET WITH THE PROGRAM.
THERE IS DAVID ZIM'S COMMENT
RIGHT THERE, CONNOR.
HE SAYS SWAP THAT EAGLES/COWBOYS
PICK.
SWAP THAT EAGLES/COWBOYS PICK,
OH.
LET'S MOVE ON TO THE NEXT ONE.
IT SAYS MINNESOTA IS WINNING AT
HOME.
WOW.
MINNESOTA IS WINNING AT HOME
TAKING ON RUSSELL WILSON AND
THAT SEATTLE TEAM.
THAT IS VERY, VERY, VERY BOLD.
CONNOR, WHAT IS YOUR TAKE ON
THESE?
>> MAN, LISTEN, THE FIRST ONE, I
GET IT.
IT'S THE EAGLES.
IT'S THE COWBOYS.
IT COULD BE A PICKUP ANY SINGLE
WEEK.
IT IS NOT EASY.
BOTH TEAMS ALWAYS PLAY UP TO
EACH OTHER.
I LIKE OUR PICK WITH DALLAS.
I FEEL GOOD ABOUT IT.
I BELIEVE IN DAK PRESCOTT.
AT THE END OF THE DAY, THAT'S
WHAT MATTERS MOST.
BUT I GET THAT ONE.
THE SECOND ONE, PROBABLY IN
DALVIN COOK FROM MINNESOTA
TODAY.
THE SEAHAWKS ARE COMING OFF A
LOSS, WHICH MEANS THEY WILL BE
READY TO GO TODAY.
THEY WILL NOT SPIRAL OUT OF
CONTROL.
I KNOW THEY'RE ON THE ROAD.
MAKES THINGS TOUGH, BUT THAT
LINE IS REALLY CLOSE.
RUSSELL WILSON HAS GOT IT.
THE DEFENSIVE WILL STEP UP.
WE HAVE TO SEE IF MINNESOTA WILL
BE ABLE TO RUN THE BALL STILL.
THE FIRST ONE I GET, WE'RE NOT
CHANGING IT.
THE SECOND ONE, I AM NOT ON THE
VIKINGS RIGHT NOW.
WHAT ARE THE PEOPLE THINKING OF
THE PARLAY AND THESE COMMENTS?
>> YEAH, CONNOR.
WE ARE NOT CHANGING.
THE SECOND ONE IS OUTRAGEOUS.
12 SAYS MAC JONES.
I GOT CODY R. SAYS STEFON DIGGS
TOUCHING TWO TDs TODAY.
YOU HEARD IT HERE FIRST.
PEOPLE ARE JUST IN THE COMMENTS
GIVING OUT THEIR TAKES, JUST
POPPING OFF TAKES.
SO EVERYBODY THAT I'M NAMING,
YOU GUYS ARE WALKING AWAY WITH
HOODIES.
BUT, CONNOR, I'M GOING TO JUST
MAKE A DECISION BECAUSE
EVERYBODY IN THE COMMENTS IS
POPPING OFF TAKES.
I'M GOING TO PICK SOMEBODY.
I'M GOING TO GO WITH DAVID ZIM.
JUST FOR THE VIBES, I MEAN, THE
COMMENT WAS OUTRAGEOUS, BUT WHY
NOT.
JUST FOR THE VIBES, WE'RE GOING
TO HOOK YOU UP WITH A HOODIE.
>> OH, MAN.
SAY SOMETHING NUTS AND YOU STILL
MIGHT WALK AWAY AS A WINNER.
>> EVERYBODY WINS.
>> WE'RE ABOUT TO DROP OUR
BOLDEST BETS OF THE WEEK AND
HOPEFULLY WE DO WIN.
WHAT DO WE NEED FROM THE PEOPLE
RIGHT NOW BEFORE WE GET INTO OUR
BOLDEST BETS?
>> GET IN THE COMMENTS TO TELL
ME WHETHER YOU ARE RIDING WITH
ME, WHICH YOU PROBABLY SHOULD,
OR IF YOU ARE RIDING WITH MY GUY
OVER THERE.
MY GUY, CONNOR, LOOKING REAL
SPIFY.
IS THAT PEACH YOU GOT ON?
>> PEACH, BRINGING IT BACK FOR
"THE SQUAD RIDE."
ALL RIGHT.
LET'S SEE THESE BOLDEST BETS.
I'LL TAKE IT AWAY.
>> YEAH.
CONNOR, WHO YOU GOT, MAN?
WHO YOU COMING WITH THIS WEEK
IN.
>> MY THREE LEG PARLAY LOST BY
ONE CHASE CLAYPOOL CATCH.
SO I'M GOING TO KIND OF DUMB
THINGS DOWN AND FOCUS ON ONE GUY
AND FOCUS ON THE CHARGERS.
BUT I'M STILL GETTING CRAZY.
I'M SAYING MIKE WILLIAMS CATCHES
OR RUSHES.
TWO TOUCHDOWNS AGAINST THE
CHIEFS.
HE'S CAUGHT TWO TOUCHDOWNS IN
FOUR YEAR GAMES.
SO MIKE WILLIAMS, HE'S BEEN HERE
BEFORE.
AND THOSE ODDS ARE CRAZY.
BOOSTED TO PLUS 1,200.
IT'S BEEN DONE BEFORE.
HE'S DONE THIS PLENTY OF TIMES.
JUSTIN HERBERT HAD BEEN FEEDING
HIM.
IT LOOKS LIKE A BREAK-OUT YEAR
FOR MIKE WILLIAMS.
LET'S MAKE SOME MONEY.
WHAT DO YOU SAY?
WHAT DO YOU GOT?
>> CONNOR, HERE WE GO.
I LOVE THE LONG SHOT.
LOVE THE LONG SHOT.
BUT YOU WERE REALLY CLOSE LAST
WEEK.
I NEED TO SEE ONE GO IN, AND I
STRONGLY BELIEVE IN THE PRIME
TIME MATCHUP NINERS/PACKERS.
THERE IS A RUNNING BACK ON THE
NINERS TEAM BY THE NAME OF TRAY
SERMON, AND HE'S GOING TO GET
SOME PLAYING TIME TODAY.
SO WHAT I THINK HE'S GONNA --
WITH HIM GETTING PLAYING TIME, I
ALSO THINK HE'S GOING TO SCORE.
BUT I'M CHANGING THIS.
I KNOW YOU GUYS CAN PLACE THAT
BET.
TRAY SERMON TO SCORE.
PLACE THAT ONE IF YOU WANT TO.
BUT IF YOU GO TO DRAFT KINGS AND
YOU ADD THE NINERS WITH HIM TO
SCORE.
IT IS PLUS 250.
THIS ONE IS GOING TO HIT.
I'M TELLING YOU.
SERMON IS GOING TO GET IN THE
END ZONE.
THE NINERS WILL RUN THE BALL
AGAINST THE GREEN BAY DEFENSE.
HE'S GOING TO GET THOSE
OPPORTUNITIES.
SO I'M ROCKING WITH SERMON TO
SCORE AND THE NINERS TO WIN.
>> WHAT I WANT TO KNOW RIGHT NOW
IS WHO ARE PEOPLE RIDING WITH?
ARE THEY GOING A LITTLE CRAZY
LIKE WHEN THEY SEE TOUCHDOWNS OR
ARE THEY GOING WITH YOUR PARLAY?
AND I KNOW YOU STILL HAVE A
JERSEY TO GIVE AWAY TO THAT
EXACT COMMENT SECTION.
WHAT ARE THEY SAYING?
>> ALL RIGHT.
HERE WE GO.
WE'RE GOING TO MIX IT IN WITH
GOOD VIBES AND A LITTLE BAD
VIBES BECAUSE WE HAVE TO SHOW
THE BAD VIBES LOVE.
SO HERE WE GO.
BEN M. SAYS MIKE WILLIAMS AIN'T
GETTING ONE.
OKAY, BEN.
THAT IS OKAY.
>> WE'LL SEE.
>> CONNOR, THAT IS OKAY.
WATCH THIS, CONNOR.
BEN, YOU ARE WALKING AWAY WITH A
HOODIE.
SHOUT-OUT TO YOU, BEN.
WE'RE MOVING ON.
I HAVE NY FAN 98.
EKELER GOING TO GET WAY MORE
OPPORTUNITIES THAN WILLIAMS.
>> ALL RIGHT.
>> EKELER IS GOING TO GET WAY
MORE OPPORTUNITIES THAN
WILLIAMS, OKAY.
A FAIR TAKE.
>> HOW ABOUT BOLD?
>> WALKING AWAY WITH A HOODIE.
YEAH.
EXACTLY.
HERE WE GO.
I MEAN, THEY'RE IN THE COMMENTS,
MAN.
SHAWN STONE 514 SAYS KIRK
COUSINS.
CONNOR, I HAVE A JERSEY TO GIVE
AWAY, DON'T I?
>> YEAH, YOU DO.
KIRK COUSINS ANY TIME.
>> I MEAN --
>> KIRK COUSINS RUNNING?
FORWARD?
>> YEAH, YEAH, YEAH.
I THINK THAT'S WHAT HE SAID.
>> SHAWN STONE, WE'RE GIVING HIM
A HOODIE FOR THAT TAKE, CONNOR.
>> PLEASE.
I HOPE YOU HIT.
>> HEY, THAT WOULD BE BIG ODDS.
BIG ODDS ON THAT.
I HAVE A JERSEY TO GIVE AWAY, SO
HOW ABOUT I GIVE IT AWAY NOW?
>> PLEASE.
>> I'M IN THE COMMENTS AND I SEE
GOAT GARDEN.
GOAT GARDEN, IT SAYS TWO
TOUCHDOWNS TODAY FOR YOUR PICK,
CONNOR.
HE'S SENDING YOU GOOD VIBES.
MIKE WILLIAMS TWO TOUCHDOWNS,
BUT GOAT GARDEN, YOU ARE WALKING
AWAY WITH A JERSEY.
>> A JERSEY.
>> GOAT GARDEN GETS A JERSEY
GIFT CARD.
THAT'S EVEN BETTER THAN JUST A
JERSEY.
WELL DONE.
ALL RIGHT.
GOOD LUCK WITH YOUR MAJORS,
EVERYONE.
HOPE YOU HAD FUN TODAY.
I KNOW WE DID AS ALWAYS.
AND WE DO THIS EVERY SINGLE
WEEK, 11:00 A.M. EASTERN TIME.
I KNOW GREG GETS UP A LITTLE
EARLY.
CONGRATS TO ALL OUR HOODIE AND
JERSEY WINNING.
IN THE NEXT 24 HOURS, NOT ME,
NOT GREG, WE LOVE TO BUT BR
BETTING WILL TAKE CARE OF YOU.
THANK YOU TO EVERYONE THAT
COMMENTED.
THE COMMENT SECTION HAS BEEN
AWESOME.
YOU ARE THE REASON THAT WE CAN
DO THIS SHOW AND THE WAY IT'S
DONE.
THANKS TO OUR LEGENDS.
SHOUT-OUT TO BUTTERCUP, THOUGH.
BUTTERCUP IS THE REAL HERO.
ENJOY YOUR FOOTBALL SUNDAY.
DROP YOUR REAL-TIME TAKES.
>> WHOA, WHOA, WHOA, WHOA.
>> SOMETHING ELSE?
>> YEAH, HOODIES.
GET BACK INTO THE COMMENTS.
HEY, SHOUT-OUT TO JOE.
HE HAS A GIFT GOING ON.
I HAVE NOT MITCH TRUBISKY.
YOU'RE WALKING AWAY WITH A
HOODIE.
I HAVE WES MESS 420.
HE SAYS TWO TOUCHDOWNS.
HE'S ROCKING WITH YOU, CONNOR.
I GOT ONE MORE HOODIE IN ME.
JASON WAY 13.
HE'S SHOUTING OUT DEEP, DEEP IN
THE COMMENTS.
WE ALL KNOW DEEP DEEP IS A QUAD
RIDE LEGEND.
SO SHOUT-OUT TO YOU FOR SHOUTING
OUT.
EVERYBODY AT GEEK GEEK RIGHT
NOW.
EVERYBODY, SHOUT-OUT TO YOU.
YOU'RE WALKING AWAY WITH A
HOODIE.
IT'S TIME TO GET UP OUT OF HERE,
CONNOR.
>> WELL DONE.
ALONGSIDE GREG IVORY, I'M CONNOR
ROGERS.
SEE YOU NEXT WEEK.
SAME TIME, SAME PLACE.
HAVE A GOOD FOOTBALL SUNDAY.
>> PEACE!
♪